précise sophie thalmann
sa vie dallemane montjoire men était au
milieu je pense que vous mettez vos
milieu fabien comment ça va et ça vient
de l'extérieur
oui t'as vu laurent milliards de petits
mouvements des cheveux à sao paulo
très fort merci comment on peut faire ça
vous connaissez tous le monde là un
petit peu dans mon altaï qu'on ne
présente plus qu'a voulu rester parce
que vous veniez car mon âme en nous
laissant d'année et quand je dis à ce
film enquête sophie tu jouis elle vient
au mondial était fou a dit je serai en
retard au château mais je remplis de ma
vie si vraiment almadies sia sophie
thalmann je reste à les concernant dans
l'incantatoire mandin d'une seule pièce
ça me fait plaisir de voir un monde pour
de vrai que j'ai habité dans le petit et
joie tu vois ça fait plaisir
vous avez sa smera sûr sourire qu'on
appelle
mais là bas
hélas très beaux yeux et magnifique moi
je sais déjà en tant que garçon je
trouve très séduisant je serai ici et
vous connaissez mon hayon non oui très
généreuse très riche ce soir-là plein
dont 2,3 millions de francs à arlette
laguiller et elle a donné beaucoup
d'argent à tout sans frontières voilà et
c'est sur un très bon placement
bravo moujan millions de francs avec la
guinée coule sans frontières je connais
un peu pareil parfois bien alors comment
ça va sophie thalmann donc un mètre 80
dell grandissant les ballons et ça ça
déjà pour moi c'est prohibitif mais j'ai
mangé beaucoup de flou acheminement fois
qu'une fille soit plus haut à l'horizon
c'est pas possible j'ai représente avec
un garçon bon comme si sa suite chose
donc sophie thalmann longtemps surnommé
la girafe ou la grande godiche ou babar
petit bar à cause des oreilles décollées
comme jamais à plus bas balance demander
si ce qu'a fait mieux que la radio
présence
non je t'en prie c'est pas moi c'est
geneviève adam laurent laurent non ce
que dit geneviève au sujet de ce alors
j'ai vu geneviève non hier laurent payet
elle te fais un gros bisou c'est
peut-être le déclic de la réconciliation
car elle m'a chargé de te faire un gros
bisou
laurent est devenu chargé de te faire un
cadeau à une boîte de thon pour le poids
de ton pour les miss à c'est que c'est
la voie là il m'a dit surtout qui lui
donne qui lui dit que j'ai envie de la
revoir tous ces gens allaient bien
rancunière jeu mieux le contenu c'est le
passé qui si tout oui c'est fini c'était
des conneries
voilà bon ça va tout va bien maintenant
bien alors moi le truc bien alors donc
les girafes en tout cas ça vous a pas
empêché de devenir miss meuse a 20 ans
quand quarry semeuse à 20 ans et
rencontre la progresse lui de rennes à
21 et miss france à 22
quelle carrière est la nouvelle miss
cameroun quand même lâché 2 et en
descendent 1997 est donc élue miss
france
avec cette fameuse petite phrase jean
pierre foucault qui vous demandent
voulais faire plus tard et vous ne
répondez prendre notre place et
j'attends tout genre et vous attendez
toujours 15 millions de téléspectateurs
ont été témoins de votre ambition je
dirais même de votre arrivisme d'une
certaine façon mais voilà et vous
attendez toujours foucault est toujours
là ouais ça me tue pas il s'arrache un
ouais tu l'appelles l'atteignent voilà
alors quand on a été miss france le
reste ton toujours je passais habib
benglia qu'à croiser les gens dans la
rue sur la france partout et toujours
dans l'est toujours présent pour la paix
dans le monde tout sinon non mais quand
on est miss france sommet pour la paix
dans le monde n'est pas le cas pour
taille mais c'était un peu le même
discours pour toutes les miss mouais je
dis toujours que la misère c'est pas
juste quelque part et que tu arrives
animaux comme arlette que tuer des
animaux pour faire des manteaux c'est
dégueulasse à ses oreilles je pense
qu'il devrait
ah qu'il est mignonne et portez jamais
de vrais faux et en tentant laurent est
en train d'avouer qu'elle ne porte
jamais sa vraie fourrure vous continuez
à sourire toute la journée depuis que
cette punition est la preuve
on apprend sur ces mêmes familles soit
il va se font bien non c'est vrai est ce
que vous mettez toujours des talons avec
des maillots de bain oui toujours après
une fois connecté mais franchement on my
own dans général on est pieds nus
ouais non mais t'es pas de talent que
miles bagnasco je marche souvent qu'il
n'y en plus moi oui quand on vous offre
des fleurs vous les rendez au public
systématiquement lors ces cartes pour
moi vous les gardez vous bien
alors tu n'es qu'un madame de fontenay
que nous aimons beaucoup 11e geneviève
notre ami jean a dit il y aura un avant
et un après sophie thalmann voilà
c'était avant oui servant du calibre et
si bien dire parce qu'effectivement pour
elle les revend à prix d'allemagne
puisque vous avez publié l'envers du
diadème chez notre ami michel lafon en
tirages en coin rires ouais moi je veux
juste faire la liste un jour on a déjà
parlé donc bah vous plaignez des fêtes
locales des foires gastronomiques des
dédicaces photos des mains au cul des à
jacques faciale c'était dans le rapport
j'ai les jeunes à mallory de miss france
donc ils ont les mains au cul la
radinerie de geneviève de fontenay qui
vous a raté loire de santé un jour vous
êtes vous invite à manger la fameuse
boîte de thon avec les biscottes crs 7g
de terrible s'est déjà dit ne prend plus
de temps donc ensuite après les miss
france en 99 vous allez présenter
téléfoot vous en souvenez je vous savez
ce que c'est un petit pont par un petit
bout ouais bah oui c'est quand on passe
la balle entre les jambes
voilà un grand bond un grand fond alors
quand on passe la balle en dessous d'un
grand fou voilà un clic vous savez ce
que c'est un trick le hat trick c'est ce
que s'est passé un truc qui est très dur
fr sais pas l'expliquer à canal+
non c'est pas le coup du chapeau le hat
trick si mais c'est super dur à faire du
rex 30 ans et connaissait pas c'est
super dur est fait je sais ce que c'est
toi c'est marqué trois fois mais ça peut
être un basket rugby football et henry
est très fort et une aile de pigeon
c'est ce que c'est j'ai ce que c'est une
aile de pigeon était la télé free
combien il ya de carton jaune avant une
expulsion jaune ah ouais non carton
rouge avant une expression combien
faut-il de carton jaune avant d'être
expulsé vous êtes dur non c'est pas été
à téléfoot justement j'étais pas là pour
parler très clairement quelqu'un ça on
juger travail et y'a pas photo à combien
ça coûte
aujourd'hui vous avez quitté tf1 non
c'est juste que
et non pas proposer une émission dans
laquelle je me sentais bien
effectivement alors on vous retrouve sur
paris première vous commenterez le 6
décembre 2003 l'élection de miss monde
oui en chine à quand le reste il est
vrai par lucinda d'or et nous on fera
ici à paris je commenterai avec
christophe roux il y en a une
rediffusion le lendemain dans l'après
midi à 14h30
or mais ceci sur rtl oui dans les
tontons à la fois encore plus écouter la
radio et vous faites aussi des
commentaires d'équitation oui je
commence
ouais ils mangent prochain sur sport + 2
mars